you see what like he's he's reaching for
ice we're in pain
[Music]
here hey what's going on everybody for
first we Feast I'm Sean Evans and today
we have a hot ones reunion special
brought to you by Hot Pockets I'm joined
across the table by Tony Hawk he's a
consigli are of skateboarding icon of
the sport and pop culture more than a
dozen X Games medals named the top vert
skater every year from 1984 to 1996 he
also boasts one of the most commercially
and critically Successful video game
franchises of all time he's back sitting
across from me as we've done a couple
times over the years Tony welcome back
to the show this time around Tony we
have not only brand new lineup of sauces
but also some of our brand new hot ones
Hot Pockets the OG pocket snack the top
of the snack pyramid for crying out loud
it's a dream collaboration hot ones fans
we can't wait for you to try it but
first things first Tony welcome welcome
back to the show thank you it's an honor
I'm excited appreciate it how are you
around spicy food I kind of know you got
a I feel okay I feel comfortable I feel
I feel like it's in my
[Music]
wheelhouse
this is the classic that's the classic
okay that's pretty classic lull you into
a false sense of security I feel I feel
[Music]
okay so I've heard you talk about the
exhibition phase of your career where
you would perform everywhere from
football halftime shows to state fairs
sometimes doing demonstrations for a
crowd in the single digits what stands
out when you think about the most
bizarre setting you found yourself in as
a professional skater oh wow um I went
to Japan for some exhibitions around
those cine years and they had a skate in
a skate shop in an indoor I mean if you
imagine Tokyo the the shops aren't big
skating wasn't big the skate shop isn't
big the ceiling was not high and then
they had all these ramps that then they
would they would literally move the um
all the the clothes and the racks out
from the the center and then they just
had these two little ramps that we skate
and they're like wanted us to skate like
three times a day for a crowd
of 10 maybe I mean it was it was the
crowd were like people wandering in that
were checking out the shop so they're
just shopping and then there just
happens to be uh some guys skating store
there projectiles coming at them cuz
we're trying to do like kick flip to 5
O's on the ramps but those like I look
back on all those things fondly cuz we
just just that's how we got here and the
funny thing is we gave it our all in
those you know what I mean it wasn't
like we would half ass it we we were
trying I was hitting the ceiling with my
head all right so up here we have the
curry Verde here in the two
[Music]
spot like is it's
like it tastes like a tie dish like I
imagine that comes with noodles I think
you're on to something here that one is
pretty spicy for number two
Sean so one of the things that struck me
watching the Tokyo Olympics was just how
young some of these skaters are you know
with a pair of 13-year-olds winning gold
and silver and the women's Street
competition what's unique about skating
in terms of the age that you can learn
it Master it and then be mentally tough
enough to compete at such a high level
well I I think that there's a
misconception that that the the Young
Generation is is like a new thing that
the younger pros and such I mean I
turned Pro when I was 14 in 1982 it was
more that in my day you reached an age
of responsibility and it was like you
you're supposed to quit because you're
you've aged out of skateboarding mostly
because it just wasn't considered a job
right but then as as everything
progressed skateboard get more popular
it's in the Olympics now the age of your
sort of peak could be in your 30s maybe
even your 40s as a skateboarder but
you're also competing with people who
are killing it in their teens I don't
know of any other sport it's like that
that that runs that crazy age range but
also the reason that you see those kids
they're so Advanced is because they have
the resources they have training
facilities there skat Parks everywhere
there are foam pits there are just so
many resources for them to get better at
it and to to lean into it and and in our
day we were just discouraged from
skating get a job like grow up that's
that's what we were
told
yeah that one's really good that one is
doesn't have a shock value of the Curry
of the Cur yes so when you see kids at
the skate park these days do you find
that the slang has become totally
incomprehensible or are there certain
phrases and terms that just stand the
test of time in the sport well it's not
incomprehensible to me there is New
Slang and stuff that has been developed
because of the techniques that are being
developed um but there's newish
terminology that I understand just cuz I
skate but we didn't get that like Bol
Landing bolts what's that well you want
to land on top of your bolts the the
bolts where the trucks are because if
you land with your feet elsewhere
there's a good chance your board's going
to break or your Landing is going to be
sloppy so you land bolts it's solid land
bolts Landing bolts or the
pinch and that this is going to be hard
to explain without a skater but um the
pinch is basically when you're grinding
on your truck you find find a spot where
it's kind of between the wheel and the
truck and you can lean on it and it's
like your your truck is pinching near
your board so you almost get wheel bite
I'm getting in the weeds here so no we
love we love it uh you almost get wheel
bite but there's a balance point and
it's like your truck is pinched in and
then you can just grind and you can just
stay there for as long as possible and
uh a few people have a very special
superpower of getting the pinch getting
the pinch I'm stealing that Jamie like
he's a pinch
[Music]
master I like that one what's a piece of
archival footage that blew your mind the
most when director Sam Jones started
digging in the crates for the 2022
documentary Tony Hawk until the wheels
fall off I think the interviews that he
found cuz he found raw footage of
interviews of me and my father my father
was featuring in one video just a little
Snippets of him but he found the raw
files and my dad passed away in 1995
actually right after the first X Games
and to hear him talk about just to Muse
about skateboarding that was really
special all right Tony one of the first
people to try I know I feel so
privileged so this one right here is our
hot habanero pepperoni and sausage Hot
Pocket
okay oh
yeah that's really good
wow I never thought
to try and Savor a Hot Pocket so much
you know what I mean wow I eat them
pretty quickly I like them yeah yeah but
to like take a bite and go wow oh spice
is hidden
yeah that's good what a compliment I'm
expecting a couple boxes of these when I
leave Tony I got you always always Tony
so John Madden once said that the only
way that he'd be involved in a football
video game is if they made it a true 11
on 11 game did you have any
non-negotiables or a fixed vision of
what you thought a skateboarding game
should look like during the pitch phase
of Tony Hawk Pro
Skater um I didn't my only caveat demand
was that I I have final approval over
anything that goes out um and that
includes gameplay characters locations
tricks and when I did ask for that it
was at a time when skateboarding was
kind of on the rise but we didn't
necessarily have that sort of Leverage
or that clout and so I had to fight for
it um but it was worth it and and they
knew
that I had the best intentions you know
what I mean it wasn't like it wasn't I
was trying to covet some image or
something it was just more that no this
has got to be legitimate I want skaters
to like this that's that was my goal
like I want a skater
to be inspired to go buy a PlayStation
to play this game well mission
accomplished yeah very much so but but
that to me that was the market success
and then and then that was it like I I
thought after the first one that we made
I really thought that was going to be it
and so I thought oh we did a good one
like that was that was sick that was fun
then 11 or 12 later yeah well I mean
they called me right away when the first
one was released and they said oh we're
already working this working
yeah this next one is the spicy shark
here at number
[Music]
six eat the heat so I once interviewed
roblo and was fascinated to learn about
the rivalries that existed in Malibu
between local Surfers and inlanders did
you experience any sort of coraly to
that kind of conflict growing up in
skateboarding in the early 8s there was
this sort of rivalry between Northern
California and Southern California which
is weird because skateboarding was all
over the place there was an East Co
scene and there was a Midwest scene
there was a Texas scene but there was
this NorCal SoCal thing and even down to
there was a magazine there's Thrasher
and there's twws and so I was Southern
California that was the death row bad
boy kind of I guess yeah pretty much
yeah but but it got it got it got weird
there was a there was a big event a lot
of the NorCal crew came down for this
one event it was in San Diego um and
they they just started booing me when I
would
go um because they're rooting for
Christian o soy who was like my rival um
in terms of competition we were friends
but somehow they they you made us Define
our locations so I was San Diego
Christian ironically was from LA but he
represented NorCal and then when I would
go they would boo me and throw [__] in
the
bowl like it was wild the strangest part
of all that is that skateboarding was so
small back then we were already the
outcasts right and then now we're pitted
against each other and it was all this
infighting it was like can't we all get
along we have this like we're this big
let's just let's all go hand in
[Music]
hand I like that one like jalapeno oh
yeah it's
like to the party
spice had some shark bite of its own you
know yeah that one's
legit is it true that you almost starred
in a skateboard themed followup to Space
Jam
yes that is true I think that that's the
one that got away how close did that get
did you see like a um they presented the
idea to me that it would be skate Jam
much along the lines of of Space Jam
with all the Looney Tunes characters and
then I was going to be the the main real
person and uh I was leaning for
Australia coincidentally to work on a
different on an independent film there
and they said we want to meet you at LAX
cuz we want to we want to finalize all
the details so they met me at that
restaurant in the middle of LAX and they
said this is happening like here's here
are the script ideas here's the poster
and I remember thinking like when is
this going to happen like when you get
back we doing you know we're going to
finalize all the details like that
that's set it's happening awesome get on
the plane go to Australia in the
meanwhile they released um back in
Action which was a Looney Tunes film
with Brendan
Frasier and apparently it didn't do the
numbers they had hoped and that was
supposed to be their way to reintroduce
Looney tun's characters by the time I
got back from Australia they weren't
even calling
anymore it was gone it was just gone it
was more like what happened like it's
all meet up again this is going to be
fun right yeah this bummer you know what
we can still dream wait can we yeah I'm
so old though like no no no no I think
we still have that we do I think we
still have that prayer yeah all right
let's you hear that it's Warner Brothers
right skate Jam I'm still here still
skating still
jamming the bomb yeah all right all
right be very
careful
that one is not fun that one is spicy at
all yeah that one mostly you taste spice
you can't really differentiate flavors
of it it is uh highly concentrated hard
taste yeah no fun at all highly
concentrated when Sean says highly
concentrated you know you should be
scared it never how much do I need you
to this you're good I'm good I took a
bite I'll take another
one
never any fun yeah that one is
Hardcore so I got that's the one you
come here for dreading yeah but we
appreciate you coming back Tony oh my
God yeah my
pleasure so I got a chance to go to the
opening of sapasi with you in La my
stepson's shop yeah yeah what to you are
the ingredients the essential
ingredients of a Great Skate Shop and
how do you think think they've changed
the most from like the 1980s to now the
ingredients of a Great Skate Shop is is
uh variety for sure wait man that's
hot but I think the the main thing is to
support the local scene and to have
people that are in the know that are
experienced
skaters either uh running the place or
at least uh Consulting on it and just
trying to fost the local scene you know
it's not just about selling a
products how do you think they've
changed you see what like he's he's
reaching for ice in the in the pitchure
we're in pain here I know sometimes it
catches
me that one is gnarly man mhm here I use
a skate
term I regret taking that second bite I
do regret coming back no I don't reget
coming back hey this is what I'm here
for that's what I'm talking about I'm
here for this like I knew I knew I was
going to have a struggle yeah but the
good news is it's over and time to move
on to the next
one when you move on you move on to a
hotter one right but you know what
nothing is like what you just ate really
no nothing I'm going to need more milk
I'm not just saying this you kind of
bodied that Tony I did as you always do
yeah you know if you were in pain it
would be hard for me to tell but that's
that's the that's a superpower of
yours I'm
[Music]
uncomfortable oh
yeah I got the watermelon I've never had
a spicy watermel before but it works so
remember when I saw you last you were
talking about what a thrill it was to be
on the children's musical series Yo Gaba
Gaba where is appearing as skateboard
Johnny and Captain Kangaroo where is
that fall in your list of most treasured
TV cameos well that was the first one
big one that was my first time on TV on
Captain Kangaroo and I used to watch
Captain Kangaroo and my dad was gloating
about that
one he's like w like my son's really
doing something important here
definitely that was a bar of legitimacy
in his eyes yeah yeah so um that means a
lot to me do you have the most cherished
movie prop in your movie prop collection
oh man my most treasured movie
prop I got it back to the future
hoverboard oh um and it's signed by the
cast that's sick that's probably it
that's sick because Back to the Future
was such a catalyst uh for skateboarding
in the 80s I mean there were there's a
generation of of people who skate now
that started because they saw Michael J
fox onest board in that
movie once again Tony it's time to take
on the last dab but this time instead of
a wing we will be eating the hottest hot
pocket ever made this right here fiery
hot pepperoni featuring the last dab
this hot pocket can be purchased
exclusively on gopuff you're someone
who's pushed the limits your entire
career it's time to push another limit
Cheers Cheers
Tony
thumbs up
mhm five stars you know the hack for Hot
Pockets right when they're open like
that you just blow in and and just get
all the steam out yeah the hottest hot
pocket ever made good and what a way to
Capstone this reunion and to close
things out skating's contribution to
lingo to slang I think it's unmatched
especially in the Sports World all right
so if you'll humor what I want to do is
Bounce some skating terminology off of
you just to see if I can get a
definition while your brain slow roast
in hot sauce okay what's a grommet a
grommet is a uh young skater what's a
[__] stance well it's not a stance it's
a way of pushing so generally you would
push with your back foot keep your front
foot in position and push and then set
your back foot on the tail [__] means
you're pushing with your front foot and
people think it's like some I think it's
some bullying that goes on about manga
pushing my take did I open a can of no
but I know that people like cuz you'll
you'll he people make fun of of [__]
pushing and the only reason that I ever
discourage it is because if you're
pushing [__] that means your back foot
you can't leave it on the tail in order
to push you have to you have to maneuver
your back foot over the trucks push and
then set your front foot down and then
reposition your back foot it's just
there's a lot of things going on what's
a Hot Pocket
uh Hot Pocket is uh generally if you if
you land on your ankles uh like on your
heels too many times it just feels hot
it's not it's not a Hot Pocket it's not
full of pepperoni or spices multiple
definitions and take a look at you Tony
Hawk for the second time taking on the
wings and Hot Pockets of death hot ones
fans the limited edition hot Ones hot
pockets are available now at retailers
Nationwide in the fiery hot pepperoni
featuring the last Sab Apollo is
available exclusively on gopuff this
camera this camera or this camera let
the people know what you have going on
in your life we have Hawk vs wolf
podcast Jason Alice and I uh bird House
skateboards birdh house apparel and uh
the skate park project is my foundation
for public skate parks underserved areas
um we've been going 20 plus years and
help to fund over 700 skate parks it's
my proudest work thank you thank you
guys I have this visual of you asking
questions now that is Secret in my head
like
okay it's like a nightmare you know what
I mean yeah
yeah